hola cómo están
soy orgullosamente 4 al 15
aquí nací aquí crecí pasé muchos años de
mi vida rodeada de personas bonitas
trabajadoras y calidad como muchos de
ustedes que están aquí
jugando en el río paseando en el malecón
yendo a barrillas los fines de semana
comiendo esquites de oña malo en el
malecón
y por qué no probando el agua de
horchata en la paletería zamora
además fiel a mi estilo como buen amante
de los deportes
iba a ver a los delfines de
coatzacoalcos
que después se convirtieron en los
tiburones rojos de coatzacoalcos
y hoy ya no existen imagínense hace
cuánto tiempo pues pero no les voy a dar
más pistas porque si sigo van a adivinar
mi edad y no no se trata de eso
pero bueno sí que tiene no pasa nada
tengo 34 años soy hija soy hermana soy
esposa y soy periodista de las
divertidas porque hablo de deportes y me
encanta mi trabajo me llena de orgullo
el saber que cuando prende en la
televisión y aparezco ahí estoy
aportando mi granito de arena para
motivarlos para distraerlos para
entretenerlos y informarlos y sacarlos
un poco de los problemas personales o
profesionales que puedan estar
atravesando
además hablo de fútbol
las cosas más importantes de lo menos
importante de la vida dicen por ahí
es la primera vez que doy una charla si
es que si me ven un poco nerviosa por
favor no me juzguen pero más que
nerviosa estoy contenta contenta y
agradecida de que me hayan buscado para
poder venir aquí y platicar un poco de
mi historia de vida y no tanto
encaminada hacia el mundo del deporte
sino un plano personal porque me he
visto en muchos momentos de la vida
donde me ha tocado renacer
el renacimiento es el tema central de
ted coatzacoalcos y me gusta de hecho me
encanta la idea me encanta la idea de
hablar de renacer porque soy consciente
de los problemas y de lo que ha sido
cual sea cual cause en los últimos años
inmersos en problemas políticos sociales
económicos y también de seguridad que a
muchos muchas veces incluso nos ha
tocado de cerca increíblemente
la palabra renacer tiene dos
significados
uno literal y el otro figurado literal
es volver a nacer regresar de la muerte
y mi mamá me vio renacer y es que fui
prematura hacia los cinco meses y medio
de ese novecientos gramos mi papá se
reía de mí y me decía hija que habías en
una caja de zapatos es más no hay ni
fotos mías de recién nacida no sé ni
cómo era
y en aquel entonces un doctor le dijo a
mi mamá recién nacida señora no hay nada
que se pueda hacer es imposible
ya está no hay nada que se pueda ser
literal mi mamá me platica que me ponen
en una mesa de metal sin solución alguna
y hoy 34 años después me gustaría ver
ese médico y decirle
y estoy entera reina si no hay nada
imposible en esta vida se puede
pero más allá de eso el significado
figurado de la palabra renacer es lo que
más me gusta
y es que se trata de agarrar todas las
fuerzas para agarrar toda la energía en
busca de reinventarnos en busca de ser
cada vez mejores
de eso se trata y me imagino que muchos
de ustedes saben de qué va o lo han
experimentado
a mí me ha tocado reinventarme en muchos
momentos de mi vida y precisamente eso
es lo que vengo a platicarles en primera
instancia cuando deciden hardware de
hardware ya cual cost decidí hace muchos
años atrás para ir en búsqueda del sueño
de ser periodista deportiva desde niña
me gustaban los deportes y se lo debo a
mi papá él me lo inculcó
tuve que ir en búsqueda de ese sueño a
estudiar primero la preparatoria y
posteriormente a monterrey a estudiar la
universidad
afortunadamente hoy puedo decir lo logré
o lo logramos gracias al apoyo de mi
gente aún me falta hay mucho camino por
recorrer hasta cierto punto se vale
decir misión cumplida ahí vamos
otro momento de los que más ha marcado
mi vida donde me ha tocado reinventar me
fue cuando en 2017 con una puntería
precisa de mi jefe en aquel entonces me
llama y me dice natalie necesito que te
vengas eeuu pero me llama dos días
después de haberme comprometido con mi
novio en aquel entonces hoy en día mi
esposo y me llama en un momento donde yo
francamente me sentía sumamente estable
contenta feliz en lo personal y en lo
profesional realizada y considerada que
no me faltaba nada que así estábamos
bien en monterrey siendo felices sin
embargo asumí el reto me costó lágrimas
me costó semanas procesarlo y emprendió
el viaje a un país conocido para una
ciudad desconocida para efectos de vivir
allí una ciudad que el choque cultural y
con lo multicultural no precisamente es
lo más fácil
un trabajo donde era la misma empresa
afortunadamente seguía perteneciendo o
sigo perteneciendo univisiondeportes
pero ahora con un rol distinto ya dejaba
la calle dejaba las canchas las
entrevistas las notas de color que tanto
me apasionan y ahora amigo eeuu a estar
en un estudio a ser presentadora de
deportes yo me sentía de un inicio como
una rata de biblioteca encerrada yo
decía quiero salir pero poco a poco fue
fue parte de reinventarme me costó
lágrimas me sentía prácticamente sola
contra el mundo los primeros seis meses
que estuve allá después dos años y medio
después puedo decirles que es la
experiencia más fuerte y enriquecedora
que me ha tocado vivir en lo personal y
en lo profesional y hoy valió la pena
incluso el casarte va de la mano con el
término reinventarte o renacer porque de
vivir solo 24 horas 7 días a la semana
con tu tiempo y espacio pasas a
compartirlo con alguien más y se trata
de compartir de comprender de llegar a
acuerdos en búsqueda de un mismo fin y
así es la vida
se trata de adaptarnos para adaptarnos
muchas veces el renacer no va de la mano
con
con ser feliz no va de la mano y ni
siquiera te preguntan si quieres
simplemente los cambios llegan a tu vida
como a mí me han llegado
se puede dar la vuelta y se puede verlo
de otra manera y hoy vengo aquí no para
hablar de mí sino para hablar de una
experiencia que estoy viendo y que estoy
viviendo plena y pura de renacimiento y
que me llena de orgullo
vamos a situarnos en diciembre del 2014
cuando mi mamá la persona que más quiero
mi pilar me llama por teléfono yo
trabajaba en monterrey me dice natal y
me siento extraña algo me pasa mi cuerpo
se mueve de una manera muy extraña y no
lo puedo controlar
a lo que yo llamo a mi papá y le digo
pasa esto con mi mamá que hacemos
adelante natal y llévala contigo
la viajó a monterrey buscamos los
mejores doctores y a ojo de buen cubero
sin estudios nos dicen
es huntington
cómo se come doctor no lo entiendo me lo
voy a explicar por favor era algo nuevo
en nuestras vidas
huntington realmente no lo entendía y me
dice el doctor mira natalie el fondo
tinto no es una enfermedad genética
degenerativa prima hermana del alzhéimer
o el párkinson ok
con el paso del tiempo tu mamá perderá
movilidad perderá la capacidad de hablar
incluso de valerse por sí misma
no tiene cura
sangre se me vino a los pies la persona
que más amo la persona que durante toda
la vida estuvo orgullosa de mí ahora
estaba enferma
y a los pocos meses a principios del
mi papá sufre un micro infarto cerebral
entonces toda la atención evidentemente
se torna hacia él y hacia sus cuidados
como familia nos paralizamos y nos
chequeamos además ante mi bloqueo de
asimilar lo que estaba pasando con mi
mamá lo dejamos ahí nunca volvía al
doctor en monterrey a pedir los estudios
para ver si mi mamá tenía o no tenía esa
enfermedad extraña durante 24 meses
permanecieron guardados en un cajón de
hospital
2016 mi papá fallece la persona que me
hizo renacer en el plano espiritual
y es que la persona que más creía en mí
en lo personal y en lo profesional que
me inculcó el hoy por hoy dedicarme a lo
que me dedico que incluso yo prefería
ver el fútbol con mi papá que ir los
sábados al cine con mis amigos nos
encantaba
digamos uno mismo y compartíamos el
gusto por el deporte
él ya no estaba
y ahí me toca renacer en el plano
espiritual y procesar el tema de mi mamá
cuando él fallece a la vuelta de seis
meses la enfermedad de mi mamá cada vez
se pone peor
a veces va avanzando aún no teníamos la
certeza de que tenía en aquel entonces
ella vivía sola en veracruz no estábamos
ni mi hermana ni yo y bueno una amiga la
llevó al hospital fue un ángel en su
camino en ese momento le hacen los
estudios de nueva cuenta
llaman un día diciendo que era
huntington
entonces mi vida cambió radicalmente con
mi buen olfato periodístico le hablé de
inmediato busqué por cielo mar y tierra
a aquellos doctores en monterrey que nos
habían ayudado con los cuales nunca
volvimos para que me dijeran algo
distinto ante la negación
me llamo pobre doctor sufrió conmigo
y me dices y natalie en efecto tiene
huntington entonces ya eran dos los
resultados que nos confirmaban la
condición de mi mamá
esto me llena de mucha alegría y de
mucho orgullo hace algunos meses me
llama yo vivía en miami ahora vivo en la
ciudad de mexico
me dice natalie
me quiero ir a vivir
una casa de retiro y yo de qué hablas
mamá no no no como una casa de retiro
obviamente ante nuestra cultura siempre
creemos que ese tipo de lugares lejos de
ayudar
son
sinónimo de abandono yo no mamá
tranquila mira te quedas un tiempo con
mi hermana te quedas un tiempo conmigo y
vamos compartiendo no natalie porque
hasta eso está muy lucida
no natal y no se trata de eso se trata
de que quiero sentirme útil
pero está rodeada de más personas quiero
tener mi propia rutina quiero hacer mis
propias cosas realmente a mí ya mi
hermana nos sorprendió pero entendiendo
que era una buena decisión para efectos
de su calidad de vida y bueno
dijimos ok mamá si eso es lo que tú
quieres y quieres sentirte útil adelante
buscamos
opciones en diferentes lugares y
encontramos uno que nos encantó a las
tres y hoy me llena de orgullo que
después de 30 años que ella me decía
natalie
me has motivado por la manera en la que
naciste fuiste prematura re naciste y
afortunadamente gracias no tengo
absolutamente ninguna secuela al
contrario estoy grandota dicen que como
puede ser prematura no sí sí lo fui y
también me tocó el temblor del 85 por
cierto
pero hoy ella es la que está renaciendo
ella es la que está marcando la pauta en
nuestro camino ella es la que está
haciendo feliz en búsqueda en búsqueda
de una mejor oportunidad
en búsqueda de una mejor vida en busca
de bajo sus condiciones salir adelante
de generar y crear hasta cierto punto
esa independencia y el decir no
mis hijas trabajan tienen su vida yo
quiero mi vida no quiero depender
ninguna
de nuestras y de mis hijas no
dijimos ok
se fue a puebla y hoy es impresionante
lo que ella ha renacido es impresionante
lo que ella ha cambiado y nos llena de
paz a mí me llena de orgullo y es el
ejemplo más fuerte que más allá de que
yo haya podido renacer hace 34 años y
estar plena hoy mi mamá esté como está
me siento muy muy a gusto a casa como en
mi casa
me siento muy muy bendecida
gracias
a mi hija
y
a ley
no estoy comiendo mejor que antes
así me traten como una reina
todas las chicas aquí
adiós besos
[Aplausos]
te amo mamá disculpa en la pijama el
agarre de última hora y así lo
encontraron
pero se puede renacer y reinventarse
claro que se puede cómo
como mi mamá
adaptándonos a las nuevas circunstancias
de la vida a las nuevas situaciones y
cambios que se nos presentan en el
camino yo sé que hace muchos años las
cosas no van del todo bien en
coatzacoalcos y me duele porque es la
ciudad donde yo nací donde yo crecí
donde incluso mi gente sigue aquí pero
se puede salir adelante unidos con
fuerza siendo solidarios y no no espero
que lo hagan los políticos
definitivamente no lo espero de ellos no
espero de mi familia de mis amigos de
los de toda la vida de los que siguen
aquí día con día partiendo sela en
búsqueda de una mejor oportunidad de
vida en busca de adaptarse a las
condiciones y a las situaciones para ser
felices a pesar de que hoy las cosas son
sumamente diferentes a cuando nosotros
éramos niños definitivamente si se puede
se puede cambiar se puede cómo podemos
hacer que el 4 cual cause renazca
ni dos
unidos y no basándonos muchas veces en
la cultura que tenemos como mexicanos
que volteamos a ver cómo podemos ganarle
tiempo cómo podemos ganar el espacio
cómo podemos ganarle al de al lado al
vecino al compañero de trabajo
si no se trata de renacer siendo
personas honestas trabajadoras juntos
que juntos de la mano busquemos la
felicidad y seamos solidarios y nos
cuidamos unos a los otros y los invito a
que hoy hoy cuando vuelvan a casa
piensen que esta es una nueva vida y qué
voy a hacer con ella
lo que hizo mi mamá
renovarse fuertes y llenos de vida salir
adelante
muchísimas gracias por su atención y
arriba cuatro cuartos
[Aplausos]